[Musique]
j'ai voulu raconter l'arrivée de sarda
garriga sur les de la réunion quand il a
été nommé gouverneur de la réunion pour
venir proclamé la libération des
esclaves le 20 décembre une part de
fierté parce que ça représente une
grande histoire de la réunion
l'abolition esclavage le 20 décembre et
ça retrace aussi comment on arrivé à ce
multiculturalisme réunionnais
j'ai voulu rajouter ma petite touche on
va dire de légendes et histoires créole
des histoires longtemps avec un petit
mélange avec 6 taran la buse la dame
blanche le voile de la mariée
donc ça sera un petit mélange de
d'histoire de la réunion avec les
croyances les histoires et à des
légendes de la russe je me suis
énormément documenté en fait sur sur les
légendes de la réunion et c'est vrai que
c'était complètement facilement ça fait
déjà cinq ans qu'on travaille à peu près
avec le même maillot dur de vingt
comédiens
après ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
dans la pièce on a aussi des danseurs et
qui représente à peu près 3 de coupe
donc ça fait un total de 40 à 60
personnes ont fait partie d'une même
famille donc c'est vraiment une histoire
à partager tous ensemble
[Musique]
je t'aime et tu veux
pendant deux heures vous allez vous
amuser parce que c'est une pièce pâte
historique c'est une pièce aussi comique
c'est une pièce qui mêle le champ qui
mêle la danse qui mêle le théâtre et
pendant deux heures c'est vraiment
quelque chose je pense que vous êtes
transporté dans un autre monde
[Musique]